l'iata l'association du transport aérien
international demande au gouvernement du
canada de rouvrir sa frontière
les initiatives de dépistage de lakovic
19 d'air canada et de widgets sur des
moyens sécuritaires selon l'iata de
rouvrir cette frontière
ces solutions pourraient permettre aussi
d'abandonner la quarantaine obligatoires
l'iata prévoit une chute de 70% des
revenus des compagnies aériennes au
canada cette année plus de 400000
emplois sont en jeu avec nous pour en
parler alexandre de juniac qui est le
directeur général et chef de la
direction de l'iata
bonsoir bonsoir qu'est ce qui vous amène
à dire que nous sommes près ici au
canada à rouvrir les frontières et à le
faire de façon sécuritaire à plusieurs
choses d'abord dire que nous comprenons
la volonté des gouvernements de prendre
des mesures pour éviter de réimporter le
virus dans le pays dont ils sont notés
sur la charge après avoir demandé les
inquiéter important à population pour
comprendre ça néanmoins ce que nous
disons c'est plusieurs choses les
mesures de quarantaine que beaucoup de
gouvernements en place
elles sont d'abord complètement
dissuasive au transport aérien
c'est bien ça c'est du bon sens et quand
vous avez une mesure de quarantaine
c'est bien ça vous ne voyagez ya pas un
voyageur qui veut passer deux semaines
dans un hôtel où il avait passé dessous
est quelque part pour passer des
vacances est encore avantageux et tous
deux nous disons c'est que où nous
propose au gouvernement dans le cadre de
l'oaci et l'organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale
c'est juste à montréal d'ailleurs de
discuter la mise en place d'un
dispositif de test
deux des passagers de thèse du tous les
passagers avec maintenant que
l'industrie du test beaucoup progressé
et qu'elle permet d'envisager
assez court terme le mise en place d'un
fest systématique tout le passager pour
éviter que l'on transporte des passagers
qui seraient affectés par le virus avec
une commande hier une sécurité une
sécurisation des tests qui est très
important est-ce qu'on n'est pas déjà en
train de travailler sur cette solution
là qui doit venir au moment où elle sera
prête et dans l'ordre des choses en
matière de santé publique
voilà la réponse est oui il faut
travailler maintenant mais l'industrie
du test sera effectivement fait de très
très grands laboratoires il y en aura
sûrement d'eau dans le monde qui ont des
capacités de production de tests dits
antigel qui ont plusieurs
caractéristiques premièrement ils ont
une sensibilité supérieure à 90 7 % si
quand même limite les risques d'erreurs
parce que nous pensons être un avis tout
à fait acceptable
deuxièmement ils sont rapides quelques
minutes quand vos résultats
ils ont un coût tout à fait abordable
aux alentours de cet avis dollars ou 7 à
8 francs suisses ou cet avis de l'armée
ils sont peuvent être payées au
personnel qu'il a pas besoin d'être
immensément qualifiés et ne pas voir une
machine vous vivez un comédien opération
pour des passagers qui voyagent leur
proposer ou leur imposer même un test à
l'aéroport de départ pour vérifier
qu'ils ne sont pas infectés
c'est quelque chose qui devient ses faux
seins est-ce que vous n'est que le côté
droit est trop sévère dans ses modalités
présentement je crois que canada met en
place des mesures de quarantaine
d'histoire étaient 700 fois on a sept et
on a raté le mot qui sont qui sont un
peu excessive je pense que maintenant
ceci dit je comprends que m quand qu'on
mette en place des mesures de protection
mais ce que nous disons si si on met en
place des mesures de test il ya plus
besoin d'avoir ces mesures de protection
et sur le fond quand vous y réfléchissez
la vraie raison pour ça c'est que nous
devons vivre avec le virus
on le veuille ou non et tout là toute la
question pour le gouvernement fall
autre sens et pour les compagnies
aériennes a qui sont évidemment dans le
sens de la santé publique la
préservation de l' des intérêts
nationaux
c'est de limiter le risque un minimum
qui permet de contrôler l'évolution de
la pandémie
ce qui nous paraît raisonnable mais ça
nous permet de vivre ça permet
l'économie de fonctionner uniquement au
transport aérien mais à toute l'économie
de fonctionner dans des conditions peu
près normale avec des mesures de
sécurité qui limitent le risque à un
niveau qui nous conte il nous paraît
tout à fait voilà c'est notre
proposition discutée en cas de chaos non
seulement vous nous avez fourni
d'ailleurs un graphique qui montre qu'à
chaque fois où on a renouvelé les
mesures de quarantaine à la fin juin
jusqu'au 31 juillet ensuite le 31
juillet jusqu'au 31 août puis ensuite
les 31 ou jusqu'à la fin des temps à
chaque fois on voit un impact de cette
quarantaine renouvelé sur sur le chiffre
d'affaires et sur l'utilisation
finalement des avions donc vous dites
que dans ce contexte là vous ne serez
jamais les compagnies aériennes capables
de reprendre des activités ne serait ce
qu'un peu normal allez c'est simple le
la quarantaine c'est simplement l'arrêt
du trafic et les passagers ne veut pas
voyager ils sont exposés à une
quarantaine soit dans le pays de
destination toit dans le pays de vos
tourments et reviennent ça ccc de toutes
nos enquêtes le démontrent c'est un coup
d'arrêt quasi absolu au transport aérien
est ce que nous pensons être non
seulement ne la privation d'une immense
liberté
on est pour les individus pour les
passagers pour les citoyens mais c'est
aussi un frein considérable économique
sans transports herry a pas de reprise
rapide n'y a pas de risque fort
notamment pour un pays comme le canada
qui est si grand si on plaît et qui
dépend très très lourdement et
travailleurs pour son fonctionnement et
pour de bon la bonne reprise des grands
messieurs de gignac on s'arrête ici
l'appel est lancé
merci merci beaucoup